(serious music)
- [Narrator] Police officers in Canada are
trained as problem solvers.
(upbeat music)
So the more tools they can
carry in their toolkit,
the more opportunities to problem solve,
and sometimes it's about
building the relationship.
- What's your name?
Nick, you know what?
That was absolutely
perfect, what you just did.
You stopped, you looked both ways.
Because of that, I'm giving
you a Positive Ticket.
- My name is Ward Clapham,
I'm a 28-year veteran
of the Royal Canadian Mounted Police,
and I'm the creator of the
Positive Ticket Program.
(engine whirring)
- Nanaimo is a community of
approximately 100,000 people.
It's a great place,
and it's something that
everybody should come and see.
Since the inception of the
program of Positive Ticketing,
we've issued approximately
sixty-four hundred
tickets to youth.
- [Police Officer] I'm giving
out Positive Tickets, okay?
Do you know what a Positive Ticket is?
- [Ward] The Positive Ticket
program, it's about catching
kids doing things right.
Rewarding them for good behavior.
It could be for using a crosswalk.
- [Police Officer] Good job, there ya go!
- [Ward] Wearing a helmet
when you're skateboarding
or riding your bike.
It could be for doing your homework.
And for many officers,
it's the ice breaker
to approach young people.
- Here, I'm gonna give
you a Positive Ticket.
Here you go, Nico, thank you very much.
Mohammed, very nice to meet you, Mohammed.
- The Positive Ticket
idea really exemplifies
the Canadian values.
We're recognized as being really polite.
Super polite.
- Well that's for you.
- [Mother] What do you say?
- Thanks.
- Well, you're very welcome.
- [Ward] It's not about the ticket.
It's all about the relationship.
Because you see, what we were finding
was that the ticket for many
young people, it was a trophy.
It was a recognition that
they were a good person,
and they had never had a police officer,
let alone, maybe a caring adult,
tell them that they were worthy,
and that there was something
special about them.
- We had a whole pile of kids,
and they're all pretty excited to see me.
There was actually one kid in particular,
she was pretty shy, pretty reserved,
and dad was telling me, he says,
yeah, my daughter, who is in kindergarten,
so five years old, is scared
to death of the police.
And he says, I've been trying to tell her,
we're in Canada now, it's safe.
The police are good.
I watched her cross the street.
She did exactly what I’ve
been trying to teach the kids.
And so I gave her the Positive Ticket.
So then she got a big smile.
That's why I do this.
- [Ward] Since the
program started in 2002,
over a million Positive
Tickets have been given out
by police around the world.
Even if one percent of
those million tickets
turned into life-changing
events for young people,
that's a heck of a difference.
(upbeat music)